so you are butt naked yeah in a foreign
country yep
with your film camera I assume it's time
yeah I mean technically I had what's
called a tenor GUI which is a small
towel okay not that small of course so
you had a small towel yeah and you're in
the Japanese spa yeah with other naked
men and women there's a thing called a
con Yoko which are mixed bathing
situations where we're and there's less
and less their ever since the the 1850s
when the West opened up Japan
you know the Puritan ethic they frowned
upon the mixed bathing situations and so
a lot of those baths have sort of been
pushed out to or the countryside and so
it's rare but they still do have mixed
bathing situations and so for my book
the way the Japanese bath I've shot just
on the men's side and I've shot it in
mixed bathing situations as well it's an
incredible book that's how I discovered
you I found it in a used book store in
Pasadena it was like up on the front the
front table and I was like this is
awesome just the way it feels and like I
love black-and-white photography and I
love Japan I opened it up I was like wow
this is incredible
yeah how did you take those pictures how
do you just roll up like that and just
like butt-naked taking pictures of other
but naked people how is that not awkward
well it actually happened uh the way I
discovered it was with a girl that I was
going out with in in the early 90s in
Japan and she says let's go down and
she's Japanese and she said let's go to
Bevo which is on the southern island of
Kyushu and go to Hot Springs and I
really didn't think either way about it
other than I thought well you know I
want to do it I've been to Japan before
wanted to explore and wherever she
wanted to go was fine and then I just
fell in love with the whole thing now
fortunately she picked the town if you
had to pick one hot spring town that's
the the number one place that's ooh
awesome I mean there are other ones
there's there's nobody bitsu in Hokkaido
there's Reema
in a on Honshu there's took out Ogawa
there's other great places but beppu
really is sort of like the mecca of the
hot spring world Wow and so we went
there and I shot with some Ilford 3200
film or maybe it was team X 3200 film
but very high speed film this is sort of
low-light situation in this magical
world of steam and bathing and and those
photos actually got a lot of response so
there was sort of an 8 year gap between
shooting those early images and having
those published and people reacting to
it and then being back in Japan and
people saying oh I actually said oh I'd
like to go to a hot spring in fact I
went with my wife at the time who's
Japanese and so she said what do you
want to do my parents are gonna meet us
at your opening I had something for
Nikon and uh in Shinjuku area of Tokyo I
said it let's go to a hot spring but I
hadn't really thought it out because all
of a sudden here I'm gonna be with my
in-laws yeah you know naked in a hot
spring and which was interesting I could
only imagine yeah I think as the father
said to me collator says I could see why
you married him next time that's not
true that's not true
yeah cuz I could see that you just
obviously married him just for love yes
yeah exactly
anyway so then I continued on at that
point shooting you know seriously and
really seeing that this could be a
project because I'm often looking for
things that are you know it's too global
or too grand to say okay I want to do a
book on Japan or I want to do something
on Japan or I want to do something on
France I mean if you're working for
magazines the one thing they never photo
editor or just a editor if you're gonna
write a piece they never want to hear oh
I'm going to France I want to do a story
it's you got to be more specific so it's
always about getting specifics and so
like Jody Cobb did something for
National Geographic on the geisha in
Japan
of course more known geisha but the way
she did it was she went and she went and
photograph the Maiko which are Gatien
training I mean she really did her work
and so whatever you do you try to get
into specifics and so the bath I
discovered sort of a you know not
looking for something like that it sort
of found me but I fell in love with it
and I saw the uniqueness of it and so
that's when I started pursuing it and
the more I did just kept building upon
itself and so just like you know with
with my North Korea project which is of
course a whole country but that's a
unique aspect because of the history of
it the complications and so I'm always
looking for interesting hooks for
stories and so the way the Japanese bath
is definitely one of them and one that
I've continued and so will have the
third edition coming out by the end of
August beginning of September
yeah it's ending it's an incredible book
and and you know a few weeks ago I took
your class at Sammie's camera and I know
you do a lot of kind of like travel
classes and yet not right so that was
one that was a thing you said in that
class was be specific about what you're
shooting like if you're gonna put a book
together if you're gonna put an essay
together be specific with it and that
blew my mind it sounds simple it sounds
like yeah of course but like the the
more the more specific you can be right
the better yeah yeah you know there are
people who do you know like my good
friend at nakute who we talked about who
shot the picture of the little girl hit
by napalm you know he's a generalist he
worked he retired but for Associated
Press and so he could go out one day and
cover the Dodgers and the next day he's
he's covering a riot next day he's
covering you know Britney Spears going
to court or whatever in other words it's
it's one thing after another he's a
generalist he's not trying to do photo
essays but but but for especially
freelance people if they really want to
get their work out they should develop
bodies of work a bunch of you know
pretty single images it doesn't really
get you very far and that's definitely
the case if you ever want to exhibit and
so if you whether it's fine art or
documentary
look for specifics just like you and I
were talking about Japanese literature
and you read one of my you know favorite
books the woman in the dunes that's a
very specific story right yeah it's just
not a story about Japan correct you know
and so it's always that sort of thing
whether it's writing or photography or
anything else or a documentary I mean
look at the like somebody that I keep
talking about right now is Jimmy Chin's
book I'm sorry his series did you see it
Jimmy Jimmy chin he's the rock climbing
photographer videographer did yeah he
worked with Alex on that you guys Mary
what was it called what was it called
wow that's bad somebody in this room I
guess in fact it is a cover it's the
cover feature for digital photo Pro
magazine I did my QA with him of him
against the wall like this kind of
thought I'm talking about or something
that well yeah with Alex the shot is him
you know climbing up mm-hmm
and Sammy would you please Google that
real fast Oh free solar solo yeah there
we go thank you we've got some great
people Christian did it thank you for
just saved us right there free solo what
an amazing movie that is and I recommend
it to everybody listening today Wow
my hands were sweating yeah and that
movie especially that moment you know
like he's training for that moment he's
been failing in that moment yeah he's
got to do it for real this time I was
like oh my god here's that one mover he
has to do a karate kick and I won't tell
you know the listeners if he made it or
not that's up to you guys to see it and
you can find out but wow what an amazing
documentary they didn't of course Jimmy
was out there you know hanging you know
by rope to document it but but and I
actually did a couple of weeks ago I did
a pilgrimage to Yosemite and to the base
of El Capitan just so I could look up
and so I posted a couple of my Instagram
and it's like he really is crazy just no
no he's amazing he's incredible but
there's something how could you not I
mean what happens when you're in you
know a thousand feet you know you're not
in ropes
and you look down and you can't decide I
don't want to be here anymore
seriously the mental strength that he
has and I know in a movie you know I
don't to give anything away but they
have an MRI and they see some things
about his brain that might give him that
extra little thing about why he doesn't
panic in that situation but of course he
studies you know every inch of the rock
but but but standing at the base and
looking up made it all the more
incredible how did you feel when he was
down there a lot better standing on
terra firma then then somewhere up the
rock because it was just beyond belief I
was just in awe of what he did and of
course Jimmy does this all the time you
know in terms of documenting this sort
of thing and he has to get himself in to
position so not only is he is he
documenting it but he's got he's an
amazing climber as well you have to be
to be able to do that stuff and Elia and
it's crazy to me to think like they
touched on in the in the movie a few
times but basically like his mind set
and all of the camera crews mindset
about if Alex if we're filming him and
he falls yeah
and dies like we're not gonna be able to
live with ourselves especially if we
push him to do something he doesn't feel
comforted
just by us being there he might do
something that's like hey check this out
without of us even just by our presence
yeah and some some of the ways they they
they sort of made it a little bit less
distracting for him was by putting some
preset cameras in positions because I
really wondered how did they do some of
these close-ups of him without
disturbing him mm-hmm and that's because
they locked in some camera positions
bolted in or however they they locked it
in along the way and then you know Jimmy
would be at a distance and some of his
his other camera people were at a bit of
a distance and so they wouldn't really
interfere with him but it's definitely
correct yet how could Alex not feel the
pressure of wanting to complete it
exactly he's there the crews there you
know there were I think you know a few
months earlier or whatever there was
sort of a false start where he
I do it but he didn't quite feel right
yeah yeah I mean I think that's and I
had said to Jimmy I said I is this not
the greatest athletic feat in history
just about because and he was talking
about yeah yeah you know if you if you
you know drop a football you know in the
end zone and you lose the Super Bowl
okay you you might play next year but he
but Alex can't afford that one mistake
no and so that's what makes it even more
unbelievable my hands are sweating right
now
yeah I'm not feeling so good you got a
chalk bag with you no I did bring my
chalk I see okay then oh yeah so so
Jimmy got specific right yeah that
specific with the rock climbing he
followed Alex and he found a story and I
like the way you compared the
documentary filmmaking to a photo like
Journal essay yep I never thought like
why didn't I think of it like that
sounds that's that's awesome well just
like I said the other day you know
Rasputin turi of in Afghanistan about
the the soldiers yes I've never seen
I've heard it was trip oh I'm so
strapped oh yeah mr. English come so
hard to me but Restrepo I mean that
that's once again focused again in other
words he's not trying to do the whole
Afghan you know the conflict in
Afghanistan it's specific you go with
these one group of soldiers at this
Forward Operating Base in other words
you get in here keep going deeper deeper
deeper and so whether you're a you know
a photographer a writer or whatever you
know get specific and that makes it more
interesting yeah and and just the
exercise of of focusing in on something
I just like you know with the orangutan
series I'm doing now it sort of came
about by accident in a way I was doing
more of a general a story on on
Indianapolis and I went to the opening
of the orangutan center there mmm and
did some photos that actually I don't
know if they look simple or not but
they're the the orangutan star on the
other side of double pane plexi or it's
another material but basically that so
really tough to photograph without glare
but
I was able to do it using some
techniques with strobes off to the side
and I was just so blown away by the way
the orangutangs were completely aware of
what I was doing I know this sounds
crazy but one of them signaled for me to
turn a camera around so he could see
himself on the back of the camera oh it
is true and I know I like to joke around
but that's actually that's crazy do you
want to show you have the bullion here
yep show some pictures Christian's got
some pulled up on okay yeah that's uh
yeah so this is just what what I do is
with blurb I make it just a quick dummy
just so I can show around so I'm going
to Washington next week I'm actually in
an exhibition there but I'm also gonna
run beetwen National Geographic and I
want to show some images so this is
blurb which I would highly recommend for
people whenever they do any trip or
whatever you know document didn't put it
out now I I put a little bit of text in
there to go along with it an intro so in
case I'm not around and I leave it there
somebody could read about it but I
didn't try to design it as a book god I
don't want anybody to misunderstand and
say oh okay
if he wants to do this as a book project
and then he's trying to design it that's
not the goal at all it's strictly just
to have as a catalog and so yeah here
are some of the the images I still
wanted to do a very clean presentation
but the basic thing is let somebody let
an editor look at the images and say
okay I get it I see what mark wants to
do and then if you see at the beginning
I did set it up just with a you know the
quick you know title and then just a
two-page you know intro yeah and that's
it just people get what I'm doing and
actually if you see my other books like
the North Korea book or you show the
Japanese bath yeah we can ya see the
Japanese bath book I do the same way I
let the photos do the talking
basically it's the book to page intro I
do have captions here because I do want
people to be able to go to these
different hot springs you know so they
can go throughout the book and and say
okay here's
you know cateura oh oh so you also asked
me you know how was I able to do this
now so when I was with my wife or girl
and going out with now is Japanese you
know they obviously you know if I'm
photographing them that's not a problem
yeah but also I've worked for many years
studying Japanese and so when I was just
on a men's side you know and I didn't
have you know Mika or worse watch go or
or my other friends there I could say
you know sumimasen watashi wa shushing
caddesi and say this whole you know
think about what I was doing and you
know would you mind if I take a photo
and and and people were very cool with
it because basically you know back to to
how we started off I had won in the
beginning at least a film camera with a
28 millimeter lens just a very simple
setup so it wasn't like I had this big
you know photo gear on or anything like
that I really had nothing and so it
wasn't intimidating got you uh and I
didn't try to sneak photos I would just
do it I but I wouldn't set things up
either I want I wanted a catch capture
the reality of what was going on that's
a balance it's like a fine balanced
balancing act yeah and so it's worked
out well but I think part of it is
because I happen to just you know love
the subject is as well and that's why
now it's it's gone on for three decades
which is pretty amazing
yeah it's again you know it was the
first book that I saw that introduced me
to your work and it's just incredible
so like you know you're what's the bet
what's the balance between asking
someone hey can I take your photo versus
like just sneaking a photo because I
remember you said never sneak a photo
but like what and what if you go up to
someone and it's like the most beautiful
photo okay can I take your photos it's
gonna be awesome and they're like nah
and you're like ah no I can't take the
photo or like what if you go up to them
and you're like hey I'm what if you what
if you aren't a professional
photographer and you aren't doing a
photo book and you're like hey can I
take a picture for my Instagram you know
like that doesn't really sound that
great yeah so what do you recommend in
those situations
bribery really what but if that doesn't
work
yeah the key is there are times 100
percent what you're shooting and so when
I said about not sneaking a shot many
many many many times I'm shooting and
not asking permission in other words
could because if you once you ask
permission or do something you're
changing the the thing that you're
seeing that attracted your eye in the
first place right now if you're doing a
portrait and I really was talking more
in terms of portraits gotcha um because
portraits I would like that that human
interaction I love that that concept of
the eyes are the window to the soul now
sometimes I'll shoot tight and go for
that sort of shot like with the
orangutan sometimes I'll pull back like
the cover of the North Korea shot and
you'll see in that shot that's an
environmental portrait so it's a
portrait of a person in an environment
that relates to them she was not
thrilled about me shooting I really
wanted this shot so did you did you ask
her well I thought you know I've studied
now Korean for years that this was in
2008 I did not ask permission and I
technically wasn't supposed to be there
either in that area but I really wanted
that that shot what I'm saying I just
was easy directing traffic yeah yeah and
at that time there weren't that many
cars but enough to keep her occupied so
I was able to to sort of shoot and then
get back to where I was supposed to be
yes so there are times where we and
especially the journalists that are
working now yet they of course he can't
ask permission you know for everything
so that really does relate more to
portraiture and and what what happens
and I see a lot of people are kind of
shy and so you know they'll go the case
in point last year I was in India and a
couple of people as traveling where they
had long lenses and we're in a village
and they're like shooting these people
treating them as objects mm-hmm you know
with a long lens I said well why don't
you just walk over and say hello you
know could look what you know we're
gaijin gwai-lo you know young way
you you know whatever you want to call
us you have the foreigner coming fiery
yeah yeah I mean they see they see us so
why not you know don't be that that
tourist shooting from distance you know
make some human contact mm-hmm and and
almost always both sides are gonna gain
from that experience nobody wants to be
treated as as an object and be
photographed with a 200 millimeter lens
from across the street in creve s just
creepy yeah well but but and when I
teach workshops students say oh but III
don't want to disturb them I want to
catch them I said oh come on like they
don't see you there and then eventually
I get the people to admit that they're
just kind of shy yeah from doing it
because that's my thing that's my thing
I'm shy I don't want to come up to
someone and be like hey I can't take
your picture I'm like nah man get out of
here it's like oh well that can't happen
yeah there's a shot I did it in Spain of
these three women sitting on a bench and
they all sort of put their hands up and
actually it's funny because it looked
like the see no evil monkeys like one
had their hands over their you know eyes
you know ears whatever and it's sort of
funny that that that happened to work
out and I said wow what are they getting
so uptight about and it turned out to be
really strong image but it was an
amazing image a cue but but basically
you know interact with people I mean
what a amazing opportunity for those who
have a chance to travel to get out and
interface and yes you will run across
people that don't want their picture
taken and they have a right not to have
their shot you know done so mm-hmm so
that's okay so but don't take it
personally just like okay you know
that's fine now sometimes people would
be a little shy and they're like oh no
no no no but but you can also you know
read that and it's playful a little bit
yeah there's some hint that I'll come on
just you know one or and then you could
do and then you you created this you
know human you know person-to-person
exchange which is really fantastic we
should not be traveling the world in a
bubble we really need to to interface
and I think you see that a lot of Tours
and stuff right people go from one place
to another and it
like that they're at an aquarium looking
in at the different culture but they're
not immersing in that culture and and
you know the excuse can be oh I don't
speak the language I don't do this or
that it's like but those are excuses got
to break through that so what do you do
to break through that when you travel
well I do actually try to learn some
some words and whatever the local
language is and yeah I've put a lot of
time in you know studying you know
Japanese and Korean and now more
recently Chinese Mandarin because I'm
actually for the second year in a row
teaching a workshop in Shanghai that's
awesome and we had an amazing time last
year was with nakute and then this year
was Sandra Miller who if your listeners
don't know me her followers don't know
him he's an amazing amazing portraitist
that he has a fantastic back story where
he had cancer and he didn't know if he
was gonna survive or not and he decided
to do this homage to all the
photographer's that he loved and that
motivated him in his career and so he
worked with John Malkovich and John
played different parts and all these
historic photos but it's a fantastic
series so you guys have to check that
out for sure but but so so Sandra and I
are gonna teach together this year in
August in Shanghai and so even though
students are fantastic and some of them
speak English and we have a translator
there I want to have a little more
direct you know contact to not you know
rely so much on the on the translator
but I mean I felt no distance at all
from the students last time with it with
a language barrier I mean really are so
much you know nonverbal communication
that we can do I mean you know you get
onto an airplane and you hear you know
the endless you know thing about well I
shouldn't say the the safety things
those are important to hear but I mean
all these are now anyway yeah and and
and you hear that on a train or whatever
and you realize that so much stuff you
really don't have to to hear mmm you
know that to really communicate there's
just some basic things we need and so
you know when I worked
did a book in Iran in 2007 I went twice
so I studied Farsi for a while
Wow so you can't speak every language
for out now you know been in 98
countries you can't speak every language
but if you pick up a few words you can
at least start you know a little dialog
you know you say hello thank you you
know those sort of things and and it at
the very least especially with my accent
I'll get a good laugh from the reaction
from people but it's appreciated and I
think that's that's probably the first
part of you know breaking the ice with
people yeah just you know whether you
say Niihau or you know any like I say o
or konnichiwa or or whatever you know
it's great yeah that makes sense yeah
and because then you put in the effort
to learn their language and like that's
cool that's nice appreciated yeah I mean
it I mean if you have a tours from China
come over here and they say howdy it's
like well I don't know if if that's the
English you should be learning but
that's okay it'd be it'd be it'd be a
good time if they if someone came up to
me and said howdy I would like ya get
into a selfie with them in a second
absolutely but usually they just hand me
the camera say oh could you take a
picture of me with Sammy or you know
another one of my friends it's like I
said oh you know I mean your picture Wow
okay fine all right so you learn the
language yeah are you saying an airbnb
z' when you go to these 98 countries or
are you staying and people's houses that
you a friend of a friend kind of thing
or you know that's a great question
because that that is actually an aspect
for me where I do have a bit of shyness
I really prefer my own space yeah
and so I'd rather stay at a place that's
not that expensive or whatever and have
my own room rather than sharing a nicer
place with somebody else unless I could
have my own room there as well I really
do need my sort of my own time yes
headspace little yes and so I'm pretty
you know easygoing just an amazing trip
in Jordan and so and we spent one night
you know camping and just like sort of a
pup tent kind of thing and then then two
nights in the Bedouin camp which was
just fantastic and and I was fairly
basic I mean they have really high-end
ones
the middle encamps like in Wadi Rum
we stayed sort of an in-between one but
wow what a great night you know each
night to see the stars you know to go
out and and so I can have just the basic
comforts you know and and and be happy
there the key thing there I was
traveling with with other journalists in
the camaraderie was fantastic and in
front of my Jay kuzu
a whisky expert brought a whole bar with
him and said that made this great kind
of make some spices up a little bit that
spice it up a lot yeah so what was it
like in North Korea how was that I mean
how many times have you been in North
Korea up into North Korea ten times as
crazy uh yeah it's very the danger about
me speaking about North Korea a little
bit is because if I don't do the
automatic oh it's the worst place in the
world that I rented uh you know people
think ah you know you're sympathizing or
this or that but you know I've been to a
lot of rough places and of course if
you're North Korean and you speak out
against the government you're gonna
disappear and your family can disappear
so there's horrible things there but but
daily life there is much more vibrant
than people realize they're not a bunch
of robots just just you know going
around you know surviving you know in
the 90s when they had you know the
horrible you know flooding people were
desperate there and so they were mass
migrations you know into China people
trying you know you know out of you know
the need just to eat now that you know
once they moved into the 2000s things
got easier to a degree you know of
course you know it's very serious
political things I mean obviously as we
see I actually even though I'm not a big
fan of of so many of the things that the
president's doing mm-hmm I've got to say
I'm glad he's talking to
uh Kim jong-un I mean why not I mean you
know the armistice was signed in 1953
we've been in a technical state of war
since then I mean war started in 1950 so
now we're going on 70 years and not
speaking directly hasn't worked so why
not my so I think that's you know a good
thing whether I mean you know things
will work out or not who knows mm-hmm
but I do think dialogue is the best way
to go that makes sense yeah I'd rather
be talking than just like stirring up in
each other's you know in like opposite
corners well look what's happening with
Iran now I mean the you know the the you
know the war drums were beating mm-hmm
and who knows if we wake up you know and
all of a sudden you know you know we're
in a shooting war I mean these things
are very complicated we had a deal in
place that was done under the Obama
administration and maybe it wasn't the
perfect deal or whatever but people were
working together and that's the way to
do things it's a very complicated
situation and people die and it's
amazing that often the people that have
not been in a war zone you know or put
on a uniform are the ones that are
sending other people to fight you know
and yeah and that's uh that's pretty
pathetic yeah I've got you know that's a
very dangerous thing because because
Condoleezza Rice
you know said something like you about
you know getting rid of Saddam it was
worth the sacrifice it was not for her
to say that was I think it I mean she
didn't lose weight you know she wasn't
there she didn't lose family members
yeah it so it's only the family members
of people who died there who I think can
say on a personal level whether it was
worth the sacrifice that makes sense you
know yeah that makes sense so just
yes that's that's complicated stuff it
all this stuff is complicated you know
we were enemies with Japan until 1945
and now we're best friends and and you
know South Korea and North Korea
you know we're divided actually they
were annexed by Japan in 1910 there's a
very complicated history and Korea the
peninsula the whole peninsula was the
Hermit Kingdom who was not North Korea
and now in the news we hear the
simplistic stuff oh the Hermit Kingdom
Harwood Kingdom but all of Korea wanted
to hide from the West because they saw
what was going on in the 1800's with the
opium wars you know with the British
shoving opium down the throats of the
Chinese and so you have to look back at
this and stuffin and say how did we get
here
mmm in the first place and when you you
look at that I mean when we talk about
us you know regime change what that's a
great concept right well we did that in
Iran in the 1950s and we basically
installed the Shah well you know how
does that you know make the people feel
they're not mean I say oh the Ayatollah
all this you know yeah you know no big
fan of the Ayatollah back you know back
when he when Khomeini came back from
Paris but but you have to look at the
bigger picture you know instead of just
like catching this one thing and say oh
they're evil no just like that whole
axis of evil yeah speech yeah well it's
I mean people I think people are ready
to get worked up and people are ready to
eat upset about stuff and you know I
maybe it's a combination of
it's a combination of like people not
being happy with themselves you know
maybe people wanting to just kind of
like put their put their feelings out
into something else just any reason to
get upset you know project stuff out
I wonder yeah you know or or to like
maybe go with the popular like I mean
also it also is you know what the media
tells you and kind of like when we were
talking we were talking in the coffee
shop about how you you were saying how
like war journalists war photographers
they have the ability to like the the
government has the ability to if you
take a picture if you put something out
that they don't like then you're gone
you know kind of thing and that's that
changes the the freedom of dress right
yeah well and that really is a
manifestation that grew out of Vietnam
where where the journalists had free
access there and they were putting out
things that really turned the public
against the war especially as as you
know we were talking about my friend
nakute who did the picture of the little
girl hit by napalm you know Kim Fugen at
June 8th 1972 that was sort of the death
knell but also eddie adams shot of of
the assassination on the streets of
Saigon during the Tet Offensive of 1968
or the burning of the monk yeah Wow
right and so you look at those photos
since like you start to see that and
think why are we over there doing this
you know and so by the time we got to
Nick's shot in 72 the war was sort of
obviously going toward a conclusion but
that was the death knell but but but the
military learned from that and said we
can't give journalists free reign and so
now I you know you have to be embedded
things are much more controlled because
they want to send out you know as a
certain message and that is dangerous
yeah now Edward Steichen we go back to
World War 2 he formed a team of
photographers thinking that if we showed
the way war really was that nobody would
have the appetite for it that didn't
work obviously
there's a great book cuz you know I I
know you're huge reader but the lessons
of history by will and Ariel Durant
after they did the lessons or history
civilization he wrote the lessons of
history and it's only like a hundred
forty eight hundred fifty pages and in
it they talked about that in the five
thousand years of written history
there's only been like a hundred and
fifty years or something where there's
been no war and and so they came to the
conclusion that this is how humans
settle probs now up until a hundred
years ago we didn't have the ability to
have mass destruction of course like
with a Gatling gun yeah that didn't mhm
you know then of all sin yes you did
have that and then all of a sudden World
War one you start to see just gas and
everything everything else right yeah
but it's and so these days there is that
you know that whole concept of mad you
know mutually assured destruction that's
probably keeping us from doing things
yeah it probably is for the best I guess
right everyone makes sure's I'm keeping
everyone kind of you know for keeping
people from from doing something they
would regret that would change the
course of humanity Oh permanently sure
yeah it's a scary it's a scary thing uh
it's a really scary thing hopefully
hopefully nothing happens yeah we can we
can only hope but so going back to North
Korea you think it's a good thing that
they're talking and it's absolutely and
you felt that your your time there made
it feel like the people there you know
it's not as bad as well it's more of a
dynamic daily life that then we see
because I mean they don't help
themselves with the propaganda they put
out like you know whenever you see
images that they're putting out you know
kim jungeun is at a launch of this or a
launch of that you know or you see the
soldiers goose-stepping which is never a
pleasant thing to see but you know when
you're there on the streets and you're
seeing kids laughing and and walking to
school and by themselves I mean you see
little kids without fear that
you know something's gonna happen to
them on the way to or from school you
know they're out playing soccer in a
field I mean there's all the stuff
that's not sort of sexy in terms of you
know reportage you know Peter often I
see you know other photographers writers
they sort of parachute in and they they
cover something and they want to
dramatize his like oh I was in you know
North Korea and it's so evil and this
Annette of course yet as I said there
are huge issues there but if you really
take the time and look at daily life you
know that there's a lot of issues I mean
you know we drive down here and you go
down 6th Street or something around 6th
and Gladys and stuff I mean we have
thousands and thousands of people living
on the street here yeah and to walk down
there my friend Samantha who's with us
today you know work down there because
she works with the psychological things
it's like all these people are dumped
out on the street you don't like Skid
Row area yeah yeah it's crazy down there
yeah I mean to call it a row is not
enough it's it's more it's a size of a
city block yeah it's a whole working of
tents and carts and unbelievable it's
crazy it's really sad my dad he's from
from Atlanta and he came down to visit
and I was like hey we're really close to
skid road you gonna see it he's like
skid row
yeah what's what's Skid Row yeah oh well
let me show you and he's like wow this
is insane
too soon because like you pull up to a
red light there's people just in the
street you know like ma'am I'm drawing a
blank here wheelchairs wheelchairs and
crutches and there it's it's super sad
people with severe obviously major
mental illness we saw that the other day
you know somebody crossing the street
and I felt so bad or that obviously she
was in pain suffering from some huge
horrible mental thing but that dumped on
the street and so we really have to look
in first before we try to fix the rest
of the world doesn't mean we can ignore
the rest of the world but we really have
to look and I see the serious issues
here and then and and so you know maybe
sometimes Wars and things he used is you
know I mean you talk about I mean just
to bounce around a bit like some people
select the the Falklands War where the
marv anus whatever
between Argentina and Great Britain mmm
that that Argentina was having some huge
economic issues even though if you look
at a map and it's like well why aren't
those Islands part of you know Argentina
but the war happened at a certain time
that it was popular for the head of
Argentina to go after to try to get the
islands back because they were having a
bad time economically so so you do have
to look at motivations and things you
know why are we in all trumped up about
Iran right now hmm you know so you you
seem to know a whole lot about history
so are you you are you have your finger
on the dial or you you you keeping
keeping uh just keeping up on everything
essentially every day is that a way you
find your stories if you find something
if you know something's gonna go down in
a place you do you go to that place is
that like how do you choose where you go
do you go there for leisure or do you go
there for a story that's a great
question well I mean first of all it
goes back to uh so my degrees my
bachelor's is in history my masters is a
special major from Cal State LA some you
know uh born in New York grew up in San
Francisco but basically my schooling is
all out here
and so my master's is a special major
combining history and photography to do
documentary work they allowed me at Cal
State LA to make my own major what which
is amazing yes that's awesome major is
cool and so my master's thesis is on
Boston's historic sights and the
interpretation methods they use and so
obviously so I have a big interest in
history and so uh I think I've got a
good overall sense I don't necessarily I
don't wake up every morning and read you
know all the papers you know in depth
but I do try to be aware of what's going
on especially in areas that I'm focused
on like North Korea Iran I was in Iraq
two years ago it was it year and a half
ago and so I do try to keep up on
current things and I do write as you
said you know what look for stories and
as a professional travel documentary
photographer writer I do have to look in
advance for stories in order to to get
them out because if you if you're doing
print work you have to always look at
the lead time and so when we were coming
up on yet anniversary of d-day I had to
make sure so that was June 6 1944 right
and so before we're coming up to 2014 I
started pitching around stories and I
got over to France and I walked the
d-day beaches in 2013 while I could get
the material together and out to the
magazines so it could run in advance of
that so so a lot of times yeah I do look
at dates and what's coming up so so
after the tsunami in Japan because I do
love Japan and I feel very you know look
close to the country and its people
soon after the the tsunami happened 2011
I went over there
didn't have an assignment from anybody
but I just felt I want to document yeah
what's going on and so I did that that
turned out it ended up with Vanity Fair
running a piece you know with the stuff
I went back five years later actually
for North Korea I went with Pico Iyer
who's an amazing writer actually he went
ahead of me but we did something on the
cinema there hmm
which was very interesting so always
looking for hooks that that that's the
key but but sometimes it's just
unmotivated
as with a tsunami it just felt right but
then when we're coming up on a five-year
anniversary I pitched it I made another
blurr book I sent it to my editor at
Vanity Fair I said I really want to do
something on this and they they looked
at the book you know if just photos as I
said just a catalog and they said yeah
okay this makes sense and so I did that
and now
coming up on the 10-year anniversary and
so I've got to start pitching now and
that's how it works just like we have a
Tokyo Olympics coming up yes so this is
a prime time to generate a stories about
Tokyo not just specifically sports
oriented but people are gonna be focused
on Japan what our good date trips out of
the city things like that so you always
have to you know think your head
especially for print publications that
makes sense and that makes sense where
arm third time broke memories yeah no
this first broken bone broken on the one
wheel and then like the other day we
were going at it this we were at this
abandoned water park yeah on the middle
of the desert halfway to Vegas and we
were going through you know like the
lazy river that you just float along
mm-hmm it was it was abandoned so
there's no water there so we were
wheeling around it and I'd hit a rock
and went down on the same hand yeah I
can't do that I was pretty stupid I
wasn't for himself um
but okay so going back into it my
question I had a question oh yeah of
course
so like what would you say to to a young
kid or someone just just starting up
again going back to Instagram because I
think Instagram is the most accessible
way to post photos right now sure
everyone can do it yeah um you know what
would you say to to someone like that
who wants to take photography seriously
and they're seeing all these these
places they want to travel right but
they don't have the money or they don't
have the time they working a job you
know or they can't just buy a plane
ticket to go out and cover some crazy
dangerous place you know what would you
say someone like that who's trying to
get to the point where you're at right
now
well I mean I could I could give a
shameless plug for my book what do I say
okay the travel photo essay yeah III do
talk in detail about that here now I'm a
and this is my first you know how-to
book and so I go into a lot of detail
about that but the it's a different
world now when I started it was all it
was
you know magazines it was all print or
TV or radio and now a lot of PR people
they're the ones to get to be friends
with
they are looking for influencers to get
out now I'm very late to Instagram
because I was doing all the work in Iran
and Iraq and North Korea or actually I
realized she just say North Korea and
Iran Iraq came later
I hid completely from social media I
didn't want to be sort of above you know
too much in a way that would interfere
if the it was North Korea saw it too
much stuff out in like social media
comments and all this that could hurt my
ability to go there oh so okay so I
wanted to be below the line sort of
thing but then one of my sponsors
insisted that I have a social media
presence and so over tied
I thought okay yeah this is I I can do
this I can do the Instagram thing and so
I started that and so mark Edward Harris
photo there's another shameless plug but
yeah because now I I do recognize the
importance of it and that I have to get
those numbers up but I would say so for
the book I did interview some people
that have great followers and asked them
because that that was not my area of
expertise but I wanted to to know it you
know for my readers and and so they say
stay focused and so the you know one guy
specifically has pictures of himself
with animals that are smiling and he's
always in the shot and it's really funny
and people enjoy waking up and see
seeing that and and so there's people
that focus on food
the one thing you don't want to do and
sometimes I see this with great
photographers they're all over the place
sure now I do wear a lot of hats and so
mine might be a little bit more over all
over the place and others but at least
and this was some advice that I was
given at least then try to run maybe
three photos in a row of something so
it's just not too arbitrary you don't
want to confuse people that are
following you that makes sense and so
you know that you know I was in India
sort of I was generating print stories
on Rudyard Kipling's The Jungle Book so
I went to madra Pradesh which is this
fantastic area where they have a lot of
tiger reserves and I photographed that
and so I ran some photos from that on
the Instagram and then of course in the
magazines you know they ran at us a
solid story yeah and so then I had a few
photos from there then to the next thing
so the key is there are conferences if
you're a big adventure traveler there's
the eight ETA which is adventure travel
trade association there's tea bags which
is a big bloggers conference those
things are great to go to because then
you'll you know hear from these
influencers that are traveling the world
but but always have a hook so it's the
same thing you know just like you know
for a print publication and you're doing
a story you know find a niche somebody I
follow you know as a young woman in
Japan and I don't know if she's
Australian or American but sort of her
adventures around Japan either somebody
that actually just has their own son cam
and they go they find all these own sent
photos they're not doing it the same as
me you know with with people in the
shots or whatever but they're
discovering that's good though hot
springs and and so I'm learning from it
and also for photographers
you know Instagram is fantastic because
we live in such a vacuum you know
although these freelance people and so
you get to see all these interesting
people all over the world doing you know
things there's a guy named Joey el Joey
Lawrence he's a great photographer he's
fascinating to follow and he was really
one of the
people that I saw that that used it so
well a couple of people that I have to
highlight for sure on Instagram
Paul Nicklin oh yeah he's great he's I
mean he's got every time I let every
time I say oh he's got over 4 million
he's got it then over 5 million then I
say oh he's got over 5 million now he's
over 5 3 I mean by the time we finished
this he's gonna be at 6 or something now
he's under yes
so 5.4 look at that he just went up come
on Paul send a few this way come on but
I know a lot of these guys also because
I'm a contributing editor for a bunch of
photo magazines and so I did a Q&A with
Paul about his book born ice and that's
why I know Jimmy you know where I did it
for the August issue coming up is my
cover feature on him
yeah and him following Alex for free
solo that sounds cool yeah and then I
was cool and also in that same issues is
my Q&A with Steve McCurry and Steve's
the one who did the picture of the
Afghan girl with the green eyes and then
Terry Virts who's an astronaut who did
amazing photography from from the space
station says yeah that's great so I'm
constantly learning from all you know
these other photographers that I have
the opportunity to you know me and
actually my first book in 1998 was on
photographers and and that came out of
my q and a's with photographers for for
photo magazines I ended up with with
Abbeville press doing a book of 20 of
the photographers from that and so but
that ties into my history so so even
though I didn't necessarily have this
clear game plan early on I really was
lost actually so so so for you guys that
are in school still oh and you're
feeling lost who would ever believe me I
would I was lost as well but I kept
moving forward I think that was the key
thing that even though I didn't know
exactly where it gonna go I knew I had
to keep moving forward and and you know
with it there were definitely some years
like well am I gonna be able to you know
stay on course you know this and that
kiss especially in a freelance world
it's not easy you know and I also was
fortunate my first real regular giggles
with the Merv Griffin Show which was a
TV show years ago and that
gave me a good base and then I assisted
for a number of years as a photographer
and that was great for a base so for
those people who want to be professional
photographers I would definitely
recommend assisting another photographer
you know they eat you learn you know how
do if you're more of a studio person you
want to do lighting or whatever what a
great way to learn because we are in a
sort of a vacuum but following okay so
I'll throw out another name art strieber
great photographer based in LA he's very
giving on his Instagram in terms of
showing his lighting setups that's cool
and and and and so it's fantastic
Nick night I think has a whole bunch of
things where you can see you know Nick
how he does things we have these master
classes now you know that you can do in
Annie
you know lumen so actually I just posted
her my portrait of her yesterday on my
Instagram saw it did you see that yes
yeah no she's great I know she gets some
flak you know a little bit but she's
strong I mean she's which is great you
know she's got a clear vision you know
and she you know she's she's famous for
Turia's you know for being tough on
assistants said hey you know don't work
for ya if you're not tough enough then
exactly yeah you can't handle you wanna
be in the arena ya know let's go III
love it good but you come out of there
you're gonna be stronger for it
absolutely yeah I mean people people
gotta go through some stuff man you
gotta go through some fire challenge
yourself that's excellent did you said
that because it's really trained you did
it too I mean you came from Atlanta here
I mean you you're your own personal
story about you coming out here you you
took chances and and I think anybody's
successful and that's part of the reason
I love the q and A's with all these
photographers and that's I've also done
it with with people in other fields
there's sort of a common thread
you know determination and and strength
and Taking Chances you know and and and
and and you got to go for it and you
know you can't be you know overly you
know careless or this or that but you
have to realize that you've got to put
in the time and work you know I do teach
classes sometimes when I was doing more
like sort of college classes and there
were a lot of students who just thought
oh this is fun you just go around you
take
pictures but they're not learning
f-stops and shutter speeds and all that
well you know would you want to go to a
doctor that you know says oh give me
that sharp thing over there come on in
other words we're not normally in a
life-or-death situation but you have to
know your stuff in fact a photo that's
on the current issue the cover the
current issue of digital photo magazine
of these and I just stuck it on my
Instagram is if this kid jumping in
Petra between rocks and and but I was
set up on a tripod shooting a long slow
exposure because I wanted to blur the
people in the foreground and and so oh
there it is right there
great yeah and and so I wanted to you
know get the people in the foreground
blurred with a slow exposure but all of
a sudden I saw this kid sitting on the
left and I could see that he was gonna
jump across and so immediately I you
know from I went from ISO 100 to 800 and
I'm not gonna test you here even though
you just took my class but but how many
more steps is that so one hundred two
hundred is one two hundred to four
hundred is to four hundred to eight
hundred as three stops so by all of a
sudden go into eight hundred ISO I could
get up to a thousand seven a second and
also I had been shooting at f-22 but I
opened up to five point six because I
wanted to get to that thousandth of a
second in order to freeze the action and
I very quickly also put the camera on
motor drive now if I didn't know my
stuff that would have taken you know and
I couldn't just shoot a frame as a test
I mean this kid was gone in a second
yeah in other words this all happened in
a split second and I got the shot and as
a cardiac person would call this a it
was a legendary photographer who had the
pleasure to know the decisive moment you
don't want to shoot the indecisive
moments you don't want to shoot the the
decisive moment plus one or minus one
you gotta hit it and and the way you do
it is by knowing your stuff and so for
so advice so so a long answer to a short
question advice would be really know
your stuff study get into a wet darkroom
if you can you know
and I love this whole retro thing that a
lot of people are doing you know a
shooting film it's fun yeah I haven't
touched a roll of film in like 12 14
years who would have Wow
but since 2005 but that's but I grew up
shooting film and I was in a darkroom
processing it and I know f-stops and
shutter speeds because of it and so I
see anybody who wants to do that now use
it as a tool it's fantastic you it but
then getting to the wet darkroom with
your negatives just don't send it off
somewhere and have it processed I'm okay
you can have the film processed but then
get into wet darkroom stick that
negative and a negative carrier and an
enlarger and make a print and then
you'll see you know you're adjusting the
F stops you know and you and you're not
turning the light on because you can't
have a light on when you're in the
darkroom you have a red light if it's
black and white and you're feeling okay
sixteen eleven eight five six and you
just know okay those are one stops that
will make you a much better photographer
when you feel that so do your homework
that that is the key keep a notebook
also I think and a lot of students they
keep note notes on your phone that's
that's fine but I think when you commit
it to a physical book if you just carry
a little notebook with you and maybe put
some nail pictures in and if you're doin
lighting draw out schematics that's what
I did when I was assisting you know and
I I I can't draw at all but so I do
stick figures but I was able then to
repeat the lighting scenarios that we
did I knew color temperatures you know
it doesn't sound sexy it's like ooh you
know you shouldn't at 5600 or 5200
Kelvin but that's what you have to know
because that's the craft right that's
the craft and and knowing composition
lighting all this and the technical side
that's all the craft stuff and then you
know maybe once you get that down then
you can mix it with the intuition Oh
100% and it's automatic but I mean look
what look what you have here I mean you
know this sound quality's fantastic the
lighting is nice and balanced the way we
have these lights you know set up the
the NCAA Christians like you know
bringing up images right away and start
like this to it but you know your craft
that's the key and so no matter what you
do know your craft
and don't think oh I'm just gonna shoot
a bunch of pretty pictures of myself
Here I am here Here I am here how long
is that going to last right you've got
to put in the time that's probably the
best advice and then also then look for
niches but also look to yourself and say
what advantage do I have over other
people that's so good - yeah it's like
what do you what's what's your special
angle on this yeah because we all have
something yes absolutely and so you know
I think because of my interest in
learning languages and stuff the
Japanese definitely learning a language
to a decent degree enabled me to work in
in hot springs they sort of you know
work together so cool my interested
history obviously helped you know for
North Korea and you know and then Iraq
last year and off of course that Iraq I
worked with an amazing writer named Tim
novel and so of course when you team up
with people like that's great but look
to yourself first before you start
looking out and said you know do you
speak a language do you have some
special skills you know if you're a
musician maybe it but you know you still
want to do photography well if you
really speak the language of your music
maybe there's some things you could you
know go in hmm so always look for that
niche maybe you know whatever descent
you're from you know you could look into
your family history and maybe do
something there's a guy named Paul Keita
gawky who just did a book about the
internment camps in world during World
War 2 and japanese-americans were
interned here and so he did an amazing
book about his family's experiences and
he went to the National Archives in DC
found photos by Dorothea Lange that
actually I think it has his and why his
shot and so he shot these people oh look
at this heat because the seat look at
the skill that he can find as this is
live this is not dropped in later you
guys seeing that this is it right here
Christians on he knows what's up oh yeah
for sure but look at that
that is is how you and then he talks
about it so you see the history
background about 1942 and President
Roosevelt you know with this executive
order this this
to see that story so it's not a general
thing yes and very specific yeah and any
any shows the before and after shots -
in other words he shows here the people
like he found three Boy Scouts that were
saluting you know because in the
internment camps they still had Boy
Scouts and they had all this other stuff
so he found those same three Boy Scouts
and then photographed him all these
years later he found them those are all
those photos are always super
fascinating before and after yeah like
even of like like you know the Sun with
with its dad or the daughter and the mom
together and then like and then you take
it like you're a baby and then you take
it 20 years later where they're still
holding them yeah kind of thing the same
position but love those but I like those
when they're in an environment though
that's particularly interesting to me
their words let's say you know we would
talk about Yosemite earlier yes let's
say you stand at the exact same spot and
you have you're 70 in the background but
you see that you cemani is exactly the
same right but but we've aged and so
it's sort of it's kind of an interesting
thing too it shows you how you know time
takes and takes its toll on things or uh
uh but it doesn't change of course that
means somebody had some fire so maybe
there's a little bit of a you know
difference in the trainer but basically
I'd be just like when you know Ansel
Adams shot Half Dome it's still there
yeah just like that
but yet we're long gone and I'm
fascinated by that sort of thing
I actually stood at the same spot where
it once again here's the history thing
so I went to Little Bighorn for a
reactant a reenactment of you know when
Colonel Custer because he wasn't a
general after the Civil War II he went
back to he was a lieutenant colonel I
think and so he at Little Bighorn you
know he was killed right at the Battle
of Little Bighorn so I went to a
reenactment there and then I found out
about the story about Comanche which was
a horse by one of his other officers he
Comanche was the only survivor from the
cavalry side of that battle and a horse
was was was wounded it was it was just
terrible look at this again this guy is
it blowing me away with this stuff
but yeah see if he could find Comanche
the horse I'd love to see that so
Comanche survived but he was wounded and
so they were gonna dispatch him yeah you
know which is a nice way to say they
were gonna put an end to the poor thing
because he had been wounded so badly
yeah and and so so but they were able to
cart him back to a fort so I went to
this fort where they brought him to and
they said no earthly rider will ride him
again and so I actually found a
photograph of him and then I went to the
exact spot with the GPS coordinates
right man yeah and I stood exactly and
the mountain range was exactly the same
Wow as that horse you know from 1870
whatever it's like wow how amazing is
that and then last year I went to
upstate New York which was fantastic
actually I spoke at this t-bags thing
you know that I was mentioning they had
me speak to to influencers about
photography and so I went to Auburn New
York to the grave of of the officer that
had been right in Comanche when it was
killed
oh man Colonel Keogh I believe I think
his name was tough spelling on it look
at this once again there it is is that
amazing look at that so you tracked down
the story you got oh yeah civic story
you went you got your your group of
photos yeah and what do you do with
these photos well I actually made a
small print so I could actually carry
the print with me so I could actually
Cline the spot and I think that that
maybe then I had the you know the GPS I
don't I don't think the GPS what was in
advance I think I had to sort of locate
it myself and and then I ended up
writing a story that was part of
something I did on Edward Curtis who is
a photographer who photographed he did
something called the North American
Indian so it was part of a bigger story
about that and so if you if you look at
it with Curtis and you look at any uh he
documented a dying way of life which
fortunately has been brought back to
some degree but he was shooting the lady
hundreds early 1900s and there he is
once again but but Edward Curtis now he
would do some things that that you can't
do these days in a documentary thing
we're like he sometimes would bring a
headdress with him and so he would mix
different tribes you know with with
different outfits and yeah I see but but
he would also say you know things were
much looser you know back then but still
he did an amazing thing about
documenting you know a way of life
because he saw what was coming on and
then he did this book that now is one or
series of books called the North
American Indian that is worth thousands
and thousands of dollars now oh yeah
this you can get the original series of
that like they're tipped in image is so
beautifully done it's it's look at this
right here yep that's it that's cool
that magnificent look at that my
birthday's coming up Clinton so book
market yeah yeah look at that right
there that that's magnificent and so if
you read about if you read about how
what he had to do in order to get the
money together for that but look how he
looked for a specific thing that felt
right for him and then how he pursued it
so this is nothing new no this is a you
know 120 years ago well the book I think
was 1920 so but in other words so
hundred years ago what he had to do so
nothing nothing new this is this is this
is shrinks it's reassuring consistency
be specific yeah you know and just keep
on your passion that sounds awesome yeah
don't give up too soon a lot of people
actually David Allen Harvey he's
somebody to follow as well he has an
online magazine I think it's called burn
magazine but but David is a National
Geographic guy and he's also with Magnum
photos he gives a lot of great advice
and he says so many people give up too
soon they won't follow something through
enough
man you don't really have to put it in
yeah look at this I think everybody
needs to hear that it's no matter what
you do yeah yeah this is far beyond
photography
it's everything in life absolutely you
can't rent it goes to everything
everything any passion that anybody has
you know like I'm you know my dream is
to direct a feature yeah it's like man
now it's like ah seems like so much work
like I don't know if it's gonna be
possible but then like hearing this
advice is like nah just keep it up
of course yeah that's awesome well and
also you know as they say and here's you
know I do have all these canned
expressions in my brain but you know you
know the expression you know a journey
of a thousand read begins with but a
single step but your ody have taken a
lot of steps and you know what do you do
so you do some smaller you know
independent films first and it goes like
that and there's a million examples of
of people but you really never know the
route that it takes to get somewhere
until you're looking back at that route
hmm that's a good very good point
so mark before we wrap up here just real
quick you have one bag what is in your
camera bag so now I've got a think tank
bag which is excellent I've got a 26 L
which is though in saborío
like a prime 26 to 26 L is actually the
name of the bag oh it was like 26 no
that's that's a very unusual leg yeah
it's a fantastic bag because it's from
the back so in other words in some of
the places ago to really be secured with
the equipment when I have it on it's
actually protected because the equipment
I can't get to it yeah so you can't get
pickpocketed on the bag at least for
that I mean it computers on the other
side but often when you're you know on
the street you know the computers back
at it you know a safe place yeah
but also you can take the bag off and
move it around and there's sort of a
waistband so you don't actually have to
put it down and so when I was and I got
it just before I went to Wadi Rum
because it's all sand and so you don't
have put your camera equipment down or
you know camera bag down and pick up
sand and all that and there it is it's
it's a fantastic fantastic bag and
actually on my website I did put a shot
of me carrying the bag and it was no way
around to get past this waterfall yeah
and I got drenched but I put the it
comes with a as most of the great camera
bags do it comes with a sort of a rain
jacket for it but inside the bag itself
I've got a nikon d80 and a backup 810
I've got a couple of fix lenses I did
have a 14 to 24 shorten zoom but now
I've got a fixed 14 or in a fixed 20
then a 24 to 70 that's my that's a
nightcore 2.8 and one thing I would
recommend to people is try to go for
fast lenses as opposed to a lens that
has a variable f-stop meaning that as
you zoom in that f-stop changes because
then you could work in lower light now
those lenses are bigger and so that's a
trade off once again so-so so 24 to 70
then 70 to 200 to 8 and then I've got a
105 macro which is a great lens
sometimes for portraiture but often just
to shoot something close then I've got a
300 2.8 fixed and now the newest lens is
a 500 5.6 man heads but it's not that
big that's because it's 5.6 so because
of that that aperture that's that is not
that wide they can make it much smaller
but it's super sharp and so so you know
on my Instagram if you see the pictures
of the Tigers in India those were shot
with a 556 and that's all in this one
bag that this is your travel bag it's
all the 300 so big that's that's why
I've got a bigger think tank bag or
Borneo
okay because I really do have to sort of
reach out and photograph the Iraqi tanks
in the the trees and at 300 to 8 is such
a beautiful lens that is a big big lens
and so that really requires the bigger
camera bag but the 26l is is a good size
for me and I always carry two cameras
because you never know something can go
down and you don't want to be in the
middle of the say Sahara Desert and
camera doesn't work because the one
thing that editors in fact somebody told
me duffer does from a number of
photographers working for Geographic as
they say
there's never excused for not coming
back with whatever worki you get sent
out to do yeah they said we published
pictures not excuses so you got it you
know and so you're professional you
gotta go you gotta go
yeah so I have a backup camera body
which actually acts not just as a backup
but I might sometimes have a 24 to 70
when I was in Nepal on earthquake
recovery thing for Vanity Fair I had a
24 to 70 on one body and a 70 to 200 on
the other now if I'm in a dicey area
that I don't want to look overexposed
with too much case yeah camera equipment
you know the other stuff might be in a
bag and I might just have the 24 to 270
with me you know and I would say
somebody starting out now one other
piece of advice might be is really think
about mirrorless now because that's
obviously where everything's going yeah
you know so whether you do Canon Nikon
Sony Fuji film they're all good yeah and
one other thing is and I'm always
surprised in classes do know if you're
shooting a full-frame or crop sensor
camera it's an important one I know what
that means
they're not ones not better than the
other it was different but you just have
to know so when I'm saying 24 to 70 if
you're shooting a crop sensor camera
that means if you put that same lens on
your crop sensor camera it's actually
going to be magnified by 1.5 or 1.6 mm
hmm so do do you know it's important for
people to keep that in mind
absolutely mark thank you so much where
can people find you well there's a bar
down the block that I think I mean right
after this so my website is mark Edward
Harris comm and I also list workshops
that are upcoming on that and then on my
Instagram and I am getting better III
wonder % finally you know moved into the
world of social media and I love it and
I you know and I follow amazing people
as I said like Paul Nick Lynn Oh Jimmy
chin I should do a shout out for us well
you got to follow you know Jimmy and a
bunch of other
a person so my Instagram is mark Edward
Harris photo so that's basically those
two ways I can be tracked down
awesome yeah your books are fantastic
people should dig in your classes are
awesome I've never been to a travel one
but it sounds like something out I
totally don't let's do it
absolutely good thank you so much thank
you so much Chris she appreciate it yeah